-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
It is time to play a game
of deception
called "True Confessions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My first opponent tonight
is a Grammy winner,
"New York Times"
best-selling author,
and M.C. of
the legendary Roots crew.
Please welcome
Tariq Trotter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Wow! You just --
You just floated in there.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You just floated
right in there.
Welcome.
Tariq and I will be facing off
against an incredibly talented
actress and filmmaker,
who you can see every Sunday
in "True Detective:
Night Country," on HBO and Max.
Please welcome Jodie Foster.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi!
Welcome.
Thank you.
What an entrance you got.
-Thank you.
-What an entrance. Now...
-I know how to do it.
-Yes, you'd know how to do it.
Here's how this works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true, the other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then they have to come
to a unanimous decision.
Is it the truth or a lie?
Tariq, you will go first.
-Okay.
-Which envelope should he open?
What do you guys think?
1 or 2?
[ Audience shouts "2!" ]
-I think that's a unanimous 2.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Wow.
-All right, this is good.
-That is -- Is it?
-Well, it's very possible
that it's --
that it definitely happened.
-It's possible.
-It's -- All right.
-What did you have to eat?
-What did we have to eat?
-What did you have to eat there?
-Um, I didn't go.
-Right. Did you eat?
-Yeah.
What'd you have to eat?
-I don't know,
I didn't go to dinner.
I don't even know
where I wound up that day,
but I just know
I declined respectfully.
-That's a great question.
Wow.
You just nailed it right there.
-If Oprah had asked me
to dinner,
I would have known
what I missed.
Yeah, I would say.
-Yeah, I'd say -- Yeah.
So, did Quest have a good time?
-He had an amazing time.
-Was it a big party
or a small dinner party?
-It was a small dinner party.
-Like, say, what?
-What'd they have for dessert?
-Uh, they had sweet potato pie.
Patti LaBelle made it,
and she was also in attendance.
Okay, well, that sounds good.
That sounds like...
-Yeah, she made it from scratch
or was it just from her company?
-I think she made it.
It was pre Patti pie wave,
so I think she was still, you
know, making them from scratch.
-Pre Patti pie wave sounds
pretty on the level.
-I don't know.
I feel like --
I just feel like he's acting.
-I'm not that good an actor.
-I concur.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Come on!
You know what I'm saying?
Why didn't you go?
-I mean, I'm just
an introvert, man.
I was -- I regret not going,
but I was like,
"Ah, I don't want to go
hang out with the aunties."
And I should have,
but I didn't.
-But who went from the --
from the Grammys?
-Amir went.
-I know, but anyone else
that we know?
-No, she didn't invite
the Grammys.
She invited us and Patti LaBelle
just on some, you know,
Philly aunties dinner.
-This is the Grammy that had
the salute to hip hop?
-No, no, no, this was --
I want to say 2014 or '15.
This was a long time ago.
-Oh, interesting.
-Okay.
-Yeah. I mean, now --
I mean, I would go
if she invited me today.
-Yeah, today.
-But I'm never getting
another invitation.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, all right.
I think Patti LaBelle
wasn't making her
sweet-potato pie until recently.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-I think it became, like,
a business thing recently,
so I'm gonna say --
Because I know about this pie,
and I've had it,
but I feel like it was
the last 5 to 7 years
of Patti LaBelle's pie.
-Well, the pies came out --
If my memory
serves me correctly,
they came out
in like 2015 to 2016.
-Yeah.
You were there in 2014.
-'14 or '15.
Like it was --
It was definitely befo--
It was before that guy,
you know,
made her pies go viral.
He sang an ode to them.
-She had to make the recipe.
-We have to be unanimous.
We have to be
unanimous on this.
-Oh. We do?
-Yeah.
-Oh. Well...
-We're partners.
-Okay, whatever you say.
Can you tell
I'm not competitive?
-It was in --
It was in Telluride, Colorado.
-Telluride?
-Yep.
-Yeah. We didn't ask that,
but thank you for the detail.
Uh, now, I don't know.
Come on.
-I say yes. I say he's --
I say he's truthful.
-I got to go with
one of my favorite,
uh, actors of all time,
Jodie Foster.
I'm gonna say that you --
He's already laughing.
You tell the tru--
You tell the truth.
-It's a lie!
-Oh, my -- Jodie!
Come on!
'Course it's a lie!
Talking -- Patti LaBelle's pies
didn't come out till later on!
-I got the chops!
-He's got the chops
in front of Jodie Foster.
Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah. Yeah, you got me.
-Unbelievable.
It is my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
-I feel like the smoke
was clouding my...
-Yeah, I know this fake --
The fake smoke
is making me cough.
Uh, all right.
Which one?
Envelope number 1 or number 2?
[ Audience shouting ]
-One.
-One for me.
-One!
-Two!
-Okay.
[ Chuckles]
-Um, when did this take place?
-This is during probably,
uh, "SNL" or aft--
Right after -- during
"Saturday Night Live" years.
-So where were we living?
-There was a party
at David Fincher's house,
and we were outside,
and we were leaving,
and he kept --
I sat next to him.
I'm a big Nicolas Cage fan.
So I talked to him all night,
and he kept calling me "Jimbo."
"Jimbo!"
-And so we're leaving,
and all this paparazzi
was there -- not for me.
-Obviously.
-I didn't even know
if they were there for Nic--
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if they were there
for Nicolas Cage.
Anyway, he goes -- I go,
"I don't have a ride home,"
'cause I took a cab there.
This is back before Uber.
-Okay.
-so he goes,
"I'll give you a ride.
Where you going?"
I go, "The Chateau Marmont."
He goes, "I'll take you there."
So we get in, and all this
paparazzi is in front of us.
And instead of going forward,
where all this paparazzi was --
I'll never forget this --
he floors it
and drives backwards
back through the road
to get away from paparazzi
and all these people.
Did a 180.
Maybe not 90.
I'd say 70 miles an hour,
but like three blocks.
Then he went up to Sunset,
and then he dropped me
off at my hotel,
and I go, "You want
to come in for a drink?"
And he said yeah.
And then we came in,
and then he fell asleep
on my couch.
-Interesting.
[ Laughter ]
-Chateau is on Sunset.
-Right.
-So...
-Yes.
-Okay.
But you said you had --
Then you went three blocks
and you went to Sunset.
-No, three blocks
to another road,
back road thing --
I don't know L.A. --
and then up something to Sunset
and maybe a left.
-It's impossible to drive
that fast up into the Hills.
-This is like
"The Californians."
-Backwards.
-That's true.
-I don't know. I don't know.
I'm not feeling it.
-"Jimbo!"
-When was this again?
-The Jimbo part was good.
-Stop trying to throw us
off the scent of the trail.
When --
When did this take place?
-Uh, when?
I would say 2000.
I don't think I did
any movies or anything.
Maybe "Almost Famous,"
but probably 2003,
something like that.
I was in my 20s.
-Fincher's house.
Okay, 2001.
-So I did --
-Fincher's house.
He was super fun.
I had a great time.
-Okay. Fincher lives does not
live near there.
He lives further that way.
I'm not saying where,
but 2001 --
I did "Panic Room" in 2001.
So I don't know.
-Jodie knows what's up.
I think it's a lie, isn't it?
-You think it's a lie?
-I do.
-I think it's a lie.
-Yeah.
-You lie!
-Lie.
-I lied, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I wish he did --
It sounded like something
he would do.
-Yeah.
-It sounds like something
he would do, but I don't know.
No, no, I --
-You wanted to do Nicolas Cage.
-Yeah, no, I didn't even --
I was just trying to think
of a story that would --
-That would've been cool, man.
-Yeah, it would've been cool.
-It would've made you cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I wish. I wish
he drove me backwards once.
All right, all right, now we're
down to the last one here.
Here we go.
It is your turn.
Which envelope for Jodie Foster?
Is it number 1 or number 2?
-Number 1 or 2?
[ Audience shouting ]
What was that?
-It's a mix.
-One?
-I'm gonna say one.
I'm gonna say go with --
Go with number one.
-Go with the one.
-Yeah.
-Hmm. "Jimbo!"
-"Jimbo!"
Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I once projectile vomited
all over a director's face.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, can you --
Can you say the director?
-Uh, he was not an American.
-Okay.
-Um, his name was Nicolas.
-"Jodie!"
[ Laughter ]
-What was the production?
-Uh, it was a film called
"The Little Girl Who Lives
Down the Lane."
-Okay. And you were
just not feeling well?
-I was not feeling well.
I was in a recording session
for looping/dubbing,
and I said, "I really have
to go to the bathroom."
And he said, "No, no, no,
just do one more take."
And I said, "No, I really
want to go to the bathroom."
And they said, "Just --
Just do another take."
So I did another take,
and I said, "Okay. So I'm gonna
go to the bathroom."
He said, "No, just one more,"
and then I just vomited
all over his face,
and it was all coming down
his glasses.
He had little round glasses.
-Oh, he had
little round glasses?
-Yeah.
-Like John Lennon glasses?
-Just falling down.
There was orange juice involved.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Yes.
I was 13.
I think I was 13.
-Oh, wow.
-Oh, so you were
the little girl
that lived down the lane.
-Yes.
-Congrats. Congrats.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, and you just go, "Yeah,
I can't do another take."
And he was in
the recording booth with you?
-Yes. Well...
The booth, no.
It was like a stage thing.
-Oh.
-Interesting.
-Yeah. Stage thing. I mean --
-Who else was in attendance?
-I don't remember.
-Uh...
-Did you --
-There was one other person,
but I just don't remember
who they were.
-Uh, around what age?
-They were horrified.
-I was 13.
-13. Okay.
And then
you went home after that?
I went back to the hotel.
And then I felt better.
[ Laughter ]
I know.
-Yeah, it's interesting,
'cause where the studio is
and the hotel,
that doesn't make sense.
I've been there before.
-Okay. Okay.
-Uh, I don't know.
-And it was all in French.
-Oh.
-The whole film was in French?
-The dubbing/looping
was in French.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-You think that's --
-The vomiting was in French.
[ Laughter ]
-You're a method --
You're a method vomiter?
-Yes.
-Are you fluent in French?
-I am.
-Can you say something?
Like, could you --
Like, continue in French.
-Uh...
[ Speaking French ]
-That's Portuguese.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Man, yeah, I think --
I don't know.
-I gotta say...
-I think it's believable.
-I think it's totally
believable.
Yeah. I say you tell the truth.
-You're telling the truth.
♪♪
-C'est la vérité.
It is true.
-Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Have you seen
the director since?
-Unfortunately,
he's passed away.
-He passed away.
-Oh, my God.
-Well, I mean, he was like 90,
but so it's okay.
-Were you so embarrassed?
You're like, "Oh, my gosh.
I'm never gonna work --"
-That was just
the most horrible thing I --
Because I was about
to say something to him.
I was saying,
"Oh, I really have to --"
And then I threw up
all over his face.
-Oh, God!
I'm so happy.
Thank you so much for playing
this game with us tonight.
Jodie Foster.
Tariq Trotter.
We're talking to Jodie
after the break!
Stick around, everybody!